en France un billet de train coûte en
moyenne 2,6 fois plus cher qu'un billet
d'avion 16 catégorie et ce jeudi un
rapport de Greenpeace qui a comparé les
tarifs aériens et ferroviaires pour 112
liaisons européennes différentes dans
cette étude la France est sur le podium
des mauvais élèves avec le Royaume-Uni
et l'Espagne l'Hexagone enregistre la
plus forte différence de prix entre le
train et l'avion en défaveur du rail
certaines connexions ferroviaires comme
Marseille Londres coûte jusqu'à 7 fois
plus cher que l'avion ce alors que
l'impact climatique global de l'avion
peut-être plus de 80 fois plus important
que celui du train selon le rapport et
malgré les multiples incitations du
gouvernement à réduire notre empreinte
carbone pourquoi une telle différence de
prix il y a d'abord des raisons fiscales
le secteur aérien profite davantage
conséquent en la matière exemple sont de
taxes sur le kérosène utilisé par les
compagnies aériennes TVA à 10% sur les
billets internationaux et réduites sur
les vols nationaux là où une TVA à 10%
s'applique de façon générale pour le
ferroviaire un rapport de l'ONG
européenne Transport et Environnement à
révéler que pour la France le manque a
gagné de ses abattements représente 4,7
milliards d'euros en 202 une année
encore anormalement faible en termes de
trafic aérien ce chiffre grimpera à 6,1
milliard d'euros lorsque les niveaux
d'avant covid seront retrouvés on entend
beaucoup parler de voyages bas carbone
mais comment peut-on demander aux
citoyens de voyager en train quand
celui-ci coûte deux fois plus cher que
l'avion en Europe on appelle les
gouvernements nationaux notamment la
France à agir deuxième raison les
défaillances du réseau ferroviaire le
rapport souligne que plusieurs grandes
villes françaises sont isolées des
capitales européennes les plus proches
Toulouse et Barcelone n'ont pas de
liaisons directes tandis que pour faire
Marseille Rome les voyageurs sont
contraints de passer par un lion ou
Turin certaines lignes historiques comme
Paris Venise ou Andy Lisbonne ont été
fermés pendant la crise du covid-19 et
non plus rouvert depuis le réseau
français souffre également de vétusté un
rapport de la Cour des comptes pointé en
2021 le mauvais état de nombreuses
lignes elles sont anciennes dans moyenne
29,2 ans sur l'ensemble du territoire
français et 23% du territoire national
hors ligne à grande vitesse est
considéré comme hors d'âge fin février
la première ministre Elisabeth borne
avait annoncé un ambitieux plan
ferroviaire de 100 milliard d'euros
d'investissement d'ici à 2040 pour
assurer un financement pérenne le PDG de
la SNCF Jean-Pierre farandoux avait
notamment suggéré de taxer le trafic
aérien les poids lourds et les
autoroutes certains observateurs mettent
toutefois en garde contre la Kabbale
lancée contre l'avion en juin dernier
face aux propositions de l'ingénieur
Jean-Marc Jean gauvici d'instaurer un
quota de cadre vols par personne
l'économie se libérale Nicolas Bouzou
défendait que seul l'innovation pourra
nous sauver progrès des moteurs
allègement des structures
électrification partielle carburant
renouvelable la décarbonation de
l'aéronautique est en marche l'Airbus
A220 qui équipe de plus en plus nos
compagnies aériennes aimaient déjà 20%
de CO2 de moins que ces prédécesseurs
[Musique]